momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por ello le doy la bienvenida a
daniela hablando con daniela empezamos
en venezuela porque abrir cuentas en
dólares es la nueva forma de combatir la
hiperinflación cuéntenos andrés buenas
noches en este país acaban de comenzar a
circular tres nuevas denominaciones de
billetes el de 200 mil el de 500 mil y
el de un millón de bolívares esta última
que ahora es la más alta apenas equivale
a cerca de 50 centavos de dólar esto ha
hecho que crezca el apetito por los
dólares que se han vuelto del refugio de
quienes quieren protegerse de la
inflación y ahora los usan para comprar
desde un carro usado hasta un café el
gobierno autorizó recientemente la
apertura de cuentas en la divisa
estadounidense en varios bancos locales
y pretende que la digitalización que
está emprendiendo de los pagos incluya a
esta divisa ya que el papel billete
escasea cada vez más en este país
daniela y el mercado no recibió bien en
turquía el despido del gerente del banco
central pues andrés la moneda turca se
desplomó este lunes en casi un 10 por
ciento o sea hoy para comprar un dólar
se necesitan 79 libras
el viernes se necesitaban 72 el mercado
está nervioso porque el presidente de
regev tayip erdogán despidió el fin de
semana a su tercer director de la
institución en menos de dos años nacía
vocal apenas llevaba cuatro meses en el
cargo y era un fuerte partidario de
tasas de interés altas para combatir la
inflación como lo dice la ortodoncia la
ortodoxia financiera de hecho el día
anterior los tipos de interés habían
subido del 17 al 19 por ciento pero su
reemplazo es más amigo de las tasas
bajas una posición que va en línea con
la del presidente erdogán y que es muy
poco convencional en el mundo económico
daniela ahora pasamos a italia porque
los trabajadores de amazon en ese país
entraron en huelga pues a la huelga de
un día de inicio de este lunes se
sumaron alrededor de 30.000 empleados
entre los de los almacenes y los
repartidores ellos representan el 75% de
la plantilla del gigante de comercio
electrónico en ese país su protesta es
por la precariedad que denuncian de sus
condiciones laborales piden mejores
salarios y reducción de los horarios
argumentando que durante la
pandemia la empresa experimentó un boom
de ventas que quieren que se les
retribuya la empresa respondió en un
comunicado dijo que sus empleados de
tiempo completo se contratan con un
salario inicial de mil quinientos euros
brutos mensuales y que esto no está mal
daniela y en españa' los desperdicios de
naranja se están usando para generar
energías limpias cómo es esto como así
como lo dice andrés en esta época del
año en la capital de andalucía se
transforma en uno de los campos de
naranjas más grandes de europa con más
de 50 mil árboles muchas veces a fruta
va al reino unido es donde se convierte
en mermelada pero otra se desperdicia a
menudo se ven en las calles en donde se
pudren o quedan aplastadas bajo las
ruedas de los carros o hacen que alguien
se resbale antes pero ahora esta ciudad
está convirtiendo esas molestias en
energía limpia por medio de un plan
piloto impulsado por la empresa de agua
potable de sevilla
mira es un proceso muy sencillo el 50%
de esa naranja es zumo
a través de ese zumo generamos un gas o
un gas que es rico en metano que
utilizamos utilizados para producir
energía a través de un motor de
cogeneración en un proceso muy sencillo
es un proceso que no requiere ningún
tipo de aditivo y un proceso
ambientalmente controlado andrés de este
año esperan procesar unas 60 toneladas
de residuos para producir la cantidad de
energía que consumirían unos 300 hogares
en un solo día excelente iniciativa
daniela momento de conocer los
indicadores eeuu inició la semana en
positivo impulsado por el sector
tecnológico en europa le ocurrió en
turquía sacudió también a las bolsas en
especial la de madrid porque sus
empresas del sector financiero
participan en este país y el remezón
turco también llegó hasta américa
latina' analistas creen que la caída de
la bolsa de sao paulo también tuvo que
ver con este asunto y vamos con una
curiosa cifra del día en 2.9 millones de
dólares fue vendido en una subasta
digital el primer tweet de la historia
éste fue enviado el 21 de marzo de 2006
por el cofundador y actual consejero
delegado de
twitter jack dorsey el tweet de hace
exactamente 15 años dice justo creando
mi cuenta de twitter la herramienta que
se usó para la venta se llama toque no
fungible un tipo de activo digital
basado en block change que es la misma
herramienta de las cripto monedas es
como un libro andrés en la red que
permite a cualquiera verificar la
propiedad y autenticidad de determinado
activo digital y que ha explotado en
popularidad durante este año también
hablando muchas gracias como siempre por
la información económica aquí en france
24 y ustedes muchas gracias por
sintonizarnos los invitamos a que
continúen con toda nuestra programación
[Música]